Hey look guys my name is a general
welcome to episode 28 of game
programming so there actually wasn't an
episode yesterday I'm sorry about that
and in the future I'll actually tell you
what's going on right now so first of
all there actually wasn't enough so
yesterday because I'm working on a quite
a big project right now and I just don't
have time to put out an episode every
day so what's going to happen is I want
to put out an episode every two days
okay so every other day I'm going to put
out an episode of game programming and
it's going to continue like that until
actually finish up this project and when
I do it'll go back to being daily so
yeah now that we're clear with that
let's get let's get back into this so
what we have we just had we just talked
about our tiles and stuff like that and
we're still working on tiles here but
what we actually didn't cover yesterday
or not yesterday so the day before was
this this render stuff that I didn't
actually insert into here and that sort
of what what we're going to start off
now and finish you know some later
episode but um if we go back into our
screen class and what I'm doing well the
way there in case you guys don't know is
you can actually hold down control and
click on the name of whatever basically
and I'll take you to that source so if I
click on screen over here just gonna
date me to here if I click on super if I
sorry if I control click on soup it's
gonna take me to the super which is the
tile constructor if I control click on
screen it's gonna take me to the screen
class so again very useful but yeah what
I want to do is I'm just gonna like sort
of start rendering from scratch again so
I'll leave this method here just for
reference but I'm like I'm actually
gonna pop down here and make some room
for myself here so you guys can mainly
see what I'm typing so to render a tile
like a few things actually go into go
into that and you've got to think about
these things right so one of the things
that definitely go go into them is where
we actually rendered the tile now
there's many ways to do this I'm going
to be doing it on an offset based system
so in other words we're gonna we're
going to factor in the player's position
and then offset each tile accordingly
that's a very popular way to way to do
it it's um
got the only other way really of doing
it is managing edge tiles position
separately and that's not that's not you
know that's just not practical we sort
of want to automate that process and
control like I guess well in other words
if we're offset if our player has sort
of moved to the right two pixels right
then we sort of want to offset every
single tile to the right you know two
pixels or actually beat to the left two
pixels if he's moved to the right
actually would it be written right
vamoose is right then the screen sort of
moves to the left doesn't it so yeah it
would be offsetting to the left two
pixels and that's sort of how we're
going to deal with that so we probably
won't cover offsetting today but we'll
actually get on through you know rent
ringtails
first just type public void public void
render tile okay and this method is
going to be you know this method is
going to exist to render you know
individual tiles not necessarily stuff
like because previously we just had a
render method this is this is just going
to be rendering tiles and we'll have
separate methods in this frame class for
also rendering things like mobs
rendering things like lighting but the
tiles we've got a separate method and
the thing we need is the x position and
uy position so in XP and YP this will be
the individual position of the tile
finally we actually didn't know what
kind of tile we're rendering now there's
actually technically you do this in
inland multiple ways because we don't
really need to know what tile were
rendering we just need to know what
sprite we're rendering so we could
actually set it equal to a sprite rather
than a tile um and that's up to you I'll
show you guys how it works both ways but
just for you know for lack of a better
reason I guess well if if in the future
if in the future we we start playing
around with sprites so like water for
example becomes animated which probably
will um we could with a run into
problems by using sprite so I'm just
gonna type tile tile
that also make it easier because if we
suddenly change as a tile sprite we
won't have to update it in the in the
tiles random method
yeah well
give it a staff now let's import this as
well and so because we're rendering
individual tiles we sort of know what
size the tiles are well we don't know
what sort of size a tile what sizes the
tile actually is we assume that is 16
because that's what we've set it right
now but we don't know so that's why I
don't really want to just default it to
16 I sort of want to you know make a
universal for any sprite sizes or any
tile sizes so we'll type 4 and y equals
0 Y is less than and then here we'll
actually type tile dot sprite dot size
all right y plus plus and again what
this is going to do is this value is
actually 16 all right this is 16 but in
case we do make it 32 for specific tiles
for example I don't know why we would
but we might um we sort of want to look
look look ahead and be like oh actually
maybe it may be like in a few months I
might add 64 size tiles like really huge
tiles there might be a map that is just
huge like just has really big tiles you
want to sort of for say that because if
you code for four months straight and
you come back and you're like god dammit
change every single render method now
because I've just just made this one
small change you know we sort of want to
try and foresee problems that we might
run into
hence this tiled of sprite dot size
thing all right so the next thing we
need to do is actually define variable
which contains the absolute tile value
now what I mean by absolute r-value is
there's two different there's relative
values and there's absolute values and
basically what an absolute value is it's
an absolute value is just the absolute
value of something in in free space or
in this case in 2d space all right so in
other words what happens is the absolute
value will always be um it will it will
in other words if we set the absolute
value to a particular value it will
always if we set it back to that value
at any point in time it will it will
render the same result
that made absolutely no sense so I'll
explain it in a different way if we had
in fact I think I just might use
paint.net to help me out here if we had
a tile here let's just say we had tile
right over here and then we had a red
tile over here right and of course is on
square but whatever we have these two
tiles here now this tile right if I just
look at the coordinate it's sort of at
around 90 120 all right so I'll just
probably just burn my tools on this
should be less round here there
going to be a long episode so 90-120
that's the Rope that's location that
tail and then the location of this time
right is 440 380 roughly now that's all
cool right we can work out that the
distance from X is 408 444 this one 94
this one and that is the absolute value
right because whatever if we want to pop
this back into this original spot it's
going to actually it's it's 440 relative
to the actual world so it's relative to
the background almost right it's it's
the absolute position of something now
relative positions might be like this X
for example is 400 from this now that
would change right because what would
happen is if we put this X to be
relative to this X if we change this
it's going to move both of them all
right not just one of them whereas if
we're dealing with absolute positions
when we if we move if we change this X
is just going to change this X not not
this one because this one isn't relative
to it they have absolute positions all
right so it is a bit confusing but think
of an absolute position as and as a
position it's relative to the actual to
the entire world and a relative position
is a position relative to a particular
object okay so to set the absolute
position we call it Y a for y absolute
equals it would basically be the actual
the required position of it
plus any offset that we might throw at
it and because we don't actually know
that offset yet because we haven't said
it I'm just gonna put it I'm just going
to make a variable here called I don't
really want to control him variables
yeah we'll do it this way so why a will
equal y plus YP and then YP I got rid of
all my spaces and then YP will actually
change depending on the offset
okay so we'll modify this value to
account for the offset that is taking
this way and it's adding it to our the
way the Y position of the thing right
because this is the pixel that is
currently rendering which has to be 216
for for the entire height of the tile
and the location or is actually
rendering that pixel is going to be
offset by this value so primarily is
going to be offset by where it's
supposed to be located in absolute space
and then where it gets off off set it to
all right because we'll modify this
variable eventually to include the
offset what are we out right now freakin
ten minutes all right
I'm probably going to end it there guys
just because I'm I don't want to keep
this episode's short I know there's a
huge debate going on in the comments as
to you know you either want longer
episodes you want shorter episodes
whatever really I made this series to
make them short episodes again because
you know so that you guys wouldn't have
to say like half an hour a day to watch
these and be able to keep up with them
really easily so um so yeah but anyway
that's pretty much how offsets work
that's what we cover today and tomorrow
or the day after
um we'll get back into you know into
rendering this this tile so until then
guys thanks for watching please hit the
like button if you enjoyed the video and
I'll see you guys next time goodbye
you